well even Kym Fox acknowledges she
believes jussie Smollett is guilty of
faking a hate crime but the actor will
still not admit that instead his lawyer
says the us and Iroh brothers may have
put on white face to attack him
according to the court records he
smollett was very clear with police on
the night of the attack that his
attackers were white he said they had
masks on and gloves but he saw their
eyes that he saw the skin surrounding
their eyes was that a false statement
obviously you can disguise that you
could put makeup on it took me all of
five minutes to Google you know I was
looking up the brothers and one of the
first videos that showed up actually was
one of the brothers in white face doing
a joker monologue with white makeup on
and so it's not it's not implausible
it's not impossible is it implausible
Gloria Schmidt is an attorney who's
representing those brothers and she
joins us tonight
Gloria thanks very much for coming on so
you heard that suggestion that your
clients without the knowledge of Jesse
small at attacked him while wearing
white face makeup
did they it's preposterous on top of
more ridiculousness
for her to come out and say that you
know what of course anything is possible
in that in that world but probable no so
do your clients these brothers concede
that they were part of this hoax
absolutely they've they've cooperated
Tucker from day one I mean they their
main focus was always to not be part of
a fraud and you know Tucker if you look
at the very little media that they've
done and their releases that we've made
they've apologized for their role and
they feel tremendously regretful for
their participation in this so I just
want understand were they employed by
small at I read that one of them had
worked for the show had worked for his
show and they had worked for him and in
some capacity is that correct that's
correct
remember that there was a friendship
they had met on set they had known each
other for you know not more than a year
so
they they really put their trust in
someone who they thought was their
friend someone who had influence someone
who could you know make a game change
for them in their career so yes that's
that's what this is really about and
we're seeing that in the news on various
different fronts people putting their
trust in the wrong person and the worst
of Hollywood so they follow his lead
they take money from him in order to to
pull off this fake hoax they get caught
so dismal that he blames them for it and
lies about it and then beats all the
charges what do they make of that here's
the thing about the awesome Dario family
and I'm very proud to be able to say
this they are amazing people what the it
would have been very easy for them to
stay lawyer DUP for them to to just say
we're not seeing anything where we're
not gonna help the public he'll you know
we're we're we're just not they wanted
to make sure that they weren't part of
that fraud and so their their value
system really came out while they were
in custody and they went through a
realization process that what Jesse
wanted to do was tear people apart more
not bring them together and that one of
the first statements we released
actually we said that that they were not
homophobic they were not racist and that
they were not anti Trump so what do they
think the motive for this was there have
been a bunch of explanations but why do
they think small at what did this you
know I and I hate sin that answer a
question on your show Tucker but
truthfully the motives and their
intentions there's their feelings
the things that go to those things I
think will be better said from them and
when the time is right they will come
out and say their story it's just not
the right time of course they're welcome
here any time it goes through that
saying finally they do they face any
legal jeopardy at all are they done with
this process they're done and there's
there's been a lot of questions about
well now are they going to get
investigated are they looking at cocaine
Spira see charges you can't be a
co-conspirator to something that is not
illegal so Tucker for example if I asked
you to you know go out to the street and
put a noose around my neck which I would
never ask you to do that but if I had
that's not illegal
right that's just not illegal but but
calling the police and saying that
somebody did that is illegal my clients
didn't do anything illegal and they
didn't wear a white face to beat up
their boss without his knowledge so
thanks for clarifying that flourish
thank you for laughing because it's
worth laughing at good to see you Thank
You Tucker